[Music]
the early stage of development some time
boards are not only providing the
governance expertise but they're also
some of the best volunteers staff people
I mean they're writing a newsletter or
they're you know doing other things
because the organization is young
growing it doesn't have the staff yet to
do that as the organization grows and
board members have to give up kind of a
task oriented and become more policy
oriented and that's hard for some people
because an individual may like writing
the newsletter or they may like doing so
one of the things that you'll find is
that when the board makes certain
transitions some board members will say
well that's not what I want to be a part
of and they'll fall off and do other
volunteer work which i think is great
once you're at that policy level then
what we see is that that boards then
have to be a little more formal in their
work everyone's been working off the top
of their head everyone knows the history
so they know how decisions are made
you need to formalize policies and board
practices that's what we see in kind of
this Phase two and then when you get
into the largest of the largest
organizations I think you then shift the
focus where the board becomes not only
the policy setters but also the
communicators to the external audiences
be it a legislature or be it the major
fundraisers or be it but they take a
different role from a task orientation
here up now to being the best
communicators on behalf of the
organization some point the rosacea
starts getting too large and it needs
more funding or it needs more expertise
and knowledge and maturity and so you
need well gee we need some more people
one potentially to Adam because we nice
to get some donors who are board members
to add some some funding to the
organization but - we actually started
to specialize maybe we need a team
that's gonna focus on finance because we
spending too much time just talking
about the numbers at the board meeting
so let's get a couple board members that
do that so the board then starts to grow
to grow 10-15 individuals which i think
is a good-sized board in general and
then those are opportunities then for
our boards to go off-site to start
really building joint mission together
and so taking the boards out taking them
working in with management teams and
having them connect to the mission
because they see it taking the boards to
where you do the service and so you
start understanding the mission better
it's understanding how then you're gonna
come back and what things you can do
together and then the boards themselves
start looking at the rest of the outside
world
they allow the management team to not
forget that there's a larger world out
there and lots of others working in
similar areas so they can hold the
management team accountable saying I
know you're trying to get stuff done but
don't forget to look up occasionally and
make sure we're still aligned as to
where we're working or their
opportunities are working and then let's
bear down again you can get stuff done
to the oversight role is always there
the fiduciary oversight and the
oversight of the boards of the
organization's legal and fiduciary
responsibilities but then I think comes
a time when the board is there really as
a resource to help to collectively to
decide where is it we want to go what is
it that what do we want to achieve what
do we need in order to get there and how
can how does this board function in
order to take us to that point and
that's going to mean looking at the
people who come onto the board your
succession planning and your tracking of
who is available to come onto your board
the kinds of roles and responsibilities
that you find for them and it's really
important for the board and the chair to
find roles which energize and excite you
are coming onto the board there's got to
be a fit for them so that they feel that
they're making a contribution more
mature organizations often have a couple
of different types of pivot points one
pivot point might occur when there is a
change in the financial situation of an
organization
right a major donor changes its his or
her focus 2008 happens and the money
that you thought you were going to be
able to raise doesn't happen
organizations also have pivot points
when some things in the market change so
a need that existed is no longer a major
need or another provider comes in to
provide that service or you realize it
is actually a huge population that
actually has a related need that you as
an organization want to serve and so the
board being able to actually be ready
for and have the capability of helping
an organization navigate through those
pivot points is incredibly important and
then of course the other really
important pivot point is when there's a
succession when there's a change in
leadership either because the existing
leader is not no longer a good fit for
where the organization needs to go or
because they're naturally transitioning
out for some other reason and the board
really needs to step up in that time and
really navigate the organization through
a really significant change